Clarence Thomas had one of the most
distinguished legal careers in American
history he's the only second
african-american to ever serve on the
Supreme Court and Justice Thomas likes
to stay out of the spotlight he rarely
speaks to the media luckily he made an
exception for me maybe it's because I
clerk for the Supreme Court for him just
a few years ago we spoke earlier about
his judicial philosophy his contentious
confirmation hearing and his friendship
and respect for the late great Supreme
Court Justice Antonin Scalia welcome
Justice Thomas great to see you thank
you for having me it's only been 25
years since I work for you I'm totally
dating myself and that's completely fine
you know it's thinking a lot about what
I wanted to ask you in this interview
because I know you kind of love doing
any press interviews and and and that's
well established but I was thinking
about your friendship with Justice
Scalia and he was also a friend of mine
tell me about the court without him
well I think the most charitable things
to say is that it's different I think my
colleagues would agree or in this sort
of a big emptiness to it he had a way of
filling up the room with his personality
is quips as intellect as humor and you
know he's wouldn't when he's alone or in
a group he's got to be on stage and he's
just he was a lot of fun you know it's
interesting I did not know him before I
went to the court and I got to know him
and we developed a friendship a bond of
trust and and so for me it personally
it's very different and I have excellent
colleagues there and Justice Alito is
just a fabulous person justice Gorsuch
is it's just outstanding and of course
the my friends who've been there for a
while are just good people and worked
out very well but without him it's very
very different it's an entirely
different court without him justice
Gorsuch there's some reports that he's
ruffled some feathers at the at the
court is there anything to that or
how is he how is he pursued well I'm so
good I don't have any feathers so I'm
certainly not a part of that typically
hang back a little bit at the beginning
but I kind of like the fact he was when
he went right in there it's like
different for me he is a good man and I
have no idea what they're talking about
you know years ago I heard reports that
Justice Scalia was tossing things and
slamming doors and I never saw all those
I never did either and I was next door
to him so I said what are you holding
back but I'm here because I hear you're
doing all these things so no I you know
people have to say what they have to say
I don't see all those things when you're
new on the court you're trying to find
your way here it's a lot of work it's a
lot of personal adjustments you're
moving your family you're getting
through the effects of a confirmation I
don't care who that is and it is an
adjustment period this is not the Court
of Appeals this Court is quite different
from being for him on the Tenth Circuit
for me having been in DC sir you were
there in my second year so you know it's
still going through an adjustment well
we had that small office justice we had
like a closet for an office now you guys
have this really in a really nice
chamber so we had to deal with the small
tiny law clerks have those chambers in
them
I just want you to know they don't put
they put no judges no one gets in there
anymore the the court itself with the
outsiders people who never had a chance
to visit the court they hear about the
court they see that annual photo that
you all take and you all look like you
just lost your best friend I mean you're
rarely smiling and it looks really kind
of dour
an unhappy place to be I know you were
in the seminary for a time and I think
Jesus Joseph Thomas still leads that
kind of monastic life you know you don't
you know you know you know you don't
give many interviews and don't talk to
all that many people or the public eye
but is it collegial on the inside for
people who don't know about it it is a
good place to work you can disagree with
this opinion or that but I'm not the
person to say it is a sour place or it's
a dour place or that it is funereal and
it's at its atmosphere it is a wonderful
place to work I loved it in Jan
Greenberg's book in 2007 about about the
court supreme conflict she exploded this
myth that pretty much everyone had to
concede was a myth that you were like
Scalia's puppet early on and you just
agree with Scalia and all the stuff and
of course she went from case to case to
case involving race involving you know
Aryan Brotherhood prison gang members
should remember that after Fortas
yeah a long time ago and that you ended
up having your own view of jurisprudence
your own approach to judging that was
completely unique and much too sometimes
to the consternation of Justice Scalia
well you know he and I we had a cut we
had a bond but I have a long history of
being told what to do I really do that
well you know I just it's on I think
people again as I said deep free earlier
people have to say what they they have
to say it is a place where individuals
do their work nobody follows the other
person Justice Scalia didn't follow me
and I didn't follow him and I dare say
nobody if there follows another person
the reasoning of your opinions your
philosophy it's described as
alternatively formalistic rigid strictly
conservative how do you describe your
philosophy justice
I think it's get it right it's the I
think we are required to reason to a
conclusion and that's what we try to do
and try to do it in a way that it is
accessible to regular people I think
when people don't agree with you you
said you're going to a football game I
am a huge Nebraska fan we're getting
into that by the way the Cornhuskers no
I mean we're not doing that we're doing
okay but not great yeah the volleyball
team my favorite team No
volleyball is a big deal we are we have
over 8,000 people for a game that's so
people have a tendency in sports that to
be outcome oriented so you will take you
want a particular outcome you want to
win the game if the referees make a call
consistent with the outcome you prefer
then you say the referee did a great job
because that referee has somehow
benefited or it made possible the
outcome you want I think we have to be
careful not to take outcomes that we
want and backwash that into the process
of decision-making so you don't reach it
out a decision and enforce the process
you use the process and try to do it in
a legitimate way again something Justice
Scalia and I agreed on you don't justify
the outcome you reason to the outcome 28
years ago you went through the worst
confirmation spectacle in history mr.
chairman I am a victim of this process
my name has been harmed my integrity has
been harmed my character has been harmed
my family has been harmed my friends
have been harmed there is nothing this
committee this body or this country can
do give me my good name back nothing I
will not provide the rope for my own
lynching or for further humiliation no
job is worth what I've been through no
job you said at the time that I'm a
victim of this process my name has been
harm my integrity has been harmed my
character has been harmed no job is
worth what I have been through no job
was it worth it
you know that's a good question
I think we are called to do certain
things in my youth I thought I was
called to be a priest thought that was
my vocation and I think their jobs that
perhaps and experiences that you
wouldn't choose but when you're called
to do it now think about it a second the
when we go up to when we do Wounded
Warrior events or we go up to do Wreaths
Across America what do you tell the the
widows the families of the Fallen that
you were too afraid to go through a
little bit of uncertainty a little bit
of difficulty to do a job like this when
they actually were in harm's way would
you tell the young man who's a double
amputee because of war that you were
afraid to go through that the I don't
thinks anyone would choose to go through
unpleasantness but if it has to be that
to do what is right and so be it